il n'est pas très grand a l'air très
calme et semble presque inoffensif
pourtant m kim hyong-o et 9e dan de
taekwondo tout simplement ce qui se fait
de mieux au monde
alors quand il vient délivrer ses
précieux conseils à montigny le
bretonneux
les élèves sont impressionnés c'est la
première fois que je voyais mais il est
là l'énergie en fait c'est
impressionnant on a envie de faire
pareil au niveau de la respiration
comédie hot and john ça apprend à mieux
respirer à prendre donc être plus avoir
plus d'aisance dans les techniques dans
les eaux cussonneau enchaînement le coup
de pied dans les coûts de poids à 72 ans
m kim dégage toujours autant de forces
qui étant jeune et semble en harmonie
avec lui-même lorsqu'il pratiquer le
taekwondo
l'ancien président de la fédération
mondiale a vécu en france pendant une
vingtaine d'années
il enseigne l'école de la vague bleue
basée sur la respiration une méthode
d'apprentissage plein d'humilité ou la
compétition n'est pas la priorité c'est
à d'été expiration ces éléments parce
que c'est nous a marre sûr toujours
contrôler aspirations exprimées pourrait
nager en tenait n'importe qui pour
traîner sport à mathieu séparé nous
contrôler
inspiration ça c'est pau force m kim
était aussi présent à montigny le
bretonneux ce week-end pour rappeler à
ses élèves qu un art martial est une
éducation de tous les jours